we just got a huge flurry of iphone 14
pro leaks over the weekend that helped
confirm a lot of the leaks and rumors
that we just weren't sure about until
this point including reports that the
design is now finalized and we shouldn't
see any more changes after this point
which is great news and now before i get
into the very interesting details about
which ports the iphone 14 pro is most
likely to come with let's first get into
what everyone's been talking about over
this weekend and that's the brand new
hole punch cutout display
about a month and a half ago we started
to see confirmation for the original
display panel leak from shrimp apple pro
which showed two cutouts replacing the
current face id notch now initially the
idea was that the extra hole on the side
would be invisible with part of the face
id system shining through it under the
display leaving a nice pill-shaped
cutout perfectly centered in the middle
but that ended up getting debunked with
some rumor confirmation and that
confirmation actually came from ross
young who was a display analyst with a
100 track record in terms of apple leaks
including perfectly predicting the
display size of the ipad mini 6 as well
as mini led and pro motion coming to the
new macbook pros on january 12th he said
that this display panel leak was real
and that the extra hole punch would
remain visible with a new unique
two-hole concept and even though it
looks a bit weird the idea is that it
would allow the iphone to continue to
look completely different from any other
design out there which is very important
to apple but what ended up happening was
that everyone on the internet started to
create renders of this new design with
hole punch cutouts that were pretty
small and sleek but over this weekend we
got a major leak from a weibo source
that completely spoiled the party a
display schematic was leaked by a
chinese source showing a much larger
dual cutout than everybody expected but
the most important part is that it
actually kind of looks like it could be
an official leaked schematic and even
better it was confirmed by multiple
sources including john prosser who said
he was able to independently confirm
that this schematic is legitimate and
that this was likely the size of the
cutouts now the weird thing is that the
size doesn't really match the original
display panel leak from shrimp apple pro
who by the way has been saying that his
panel leak was from the back side
so it should actually be flipped when on
the iphone matching the cutout
orientation of this new schematic leak
but the part that doesn't really match
up is the size since the cutouts on the
original display panel leak seemed to be
quite a bit smaller than the ones on the
new schematic and thankfully shrimp
apple pro sent out a newsletter on
sunday to explain the entire situation
with the size difference apparently back
in august he said that the cutouts will
be weirdly big basically confirming
these recent schematic leaks that look
big and then to explain the difference
in the sizes shrimp believes that this
new schematic is for the 6.1 inch iphone
14 pro model while his original panel
leak was for the larger 6.7 inch model
which is why the cutouts look smaller
against the larger display so it looks
like apple is going to be taking the
simple route of tweaking the face id
sensor system then cutting holes around
it and then removing the black paint of
the current notch that we have which
would lead to a design that looks like
this which is exactly what i showed you
guys in a video i made a month and a
half ago with this really sloppy
photoshop sketch and while a lot of you
guys online aren't happy with the news
of the cutouts being larger than
expected i personally think it's gonna
look great especially on the max model
which i prefer
and it's gonna put the notch to shane
and speaking of the notch shrimp
confirmed that the new cutout design is
only for the pro models while the
regular 14 and 14 max models will
continue to come with the same old notch
that we currently have on the 13 models
and this right here was actually an old
leak from ross young which he recently
confirmed once again over the weekend
but the most important confirmation that
he gave us was that next year all four
of the iphone 15 models will come with
this new dual hull design hopefully with
smaller holes than we saw in this new
schematic but nevertheless this means
that the notch will finally be going
away for good on the iphone so if you're
planning on skipping the iphone 14 this
year next year is going to be awesome
for the lower end iphone 15 models now
that the notch is going to be gone and
as far as 120 hertz pro motion
technology ross young confirmed that for
the iphone 15 lineup it's still only
gonna be on the pro models and not any
of the lower end models so i would still
recommend going for the pro models right
now because 120 hertz has been my
favorite feature so far with the 13 pro
max now on top of all of these display
and design leaks we also got some
important leaks concerning the general
features and the specs for example we
got a report from taiwan's economic
daily news that the iphone 14 lineup
should have better battery life thanks
to a new 5g chip which will be produced
using tsmc's new six nanometer process
which is more efficient but on top of
that it also means that we should get
less overheating while using 5g which
has been causing some problems with the
current iphones while running high
performance tasks on 5g like gaming but
the part that i'm really looking forward
to is the addition of wi-fi 6e with the
new 6 gigahertz band which will be a
much bigger deal than the current wi-fi
6 which didn't really seem to change
much at all going further we got some
reports from a korean blogger who claims
that the iphone 14 pro will come with 8
gigabytes of ram this year and this is
after an analyst jeff poo said that we
should be getting eight gigs so i'm
pretty confident that this is gonna
happen and now another leaked feature
that we finally got some more clarity on
is under display touch id which has been
leaked for many years already and as you
guys may know i've been saying that ever
since apple allowed face id to work with
masks i honestly don't think that apple
will ever need under display touch id
and it looks like all of the leaks are
pointing to this happening first of all
shrimp apple pro confirmed that touch id
will not be coming on the iphone 14
which is something he's been saying ever
since august and even more recently
leaks apple pro has reported to eyedrop
news that apple is no longer working on
under display touch id for the iphone
which basically means that they're
completely scrapping this idea and in my
opinion this makes sense because face id
is completely exclusive to apple there's
literally nothing out there that's like
it while under display fingerprint
scanners are everywhere so i think that
apple is going to stick with face id for
many many years maybe even decades as
they improve on the technology by adding
even more layers of security now finally
the last thing i want to talk about is
the port situation and as you guys may
know i made a video a couple months back
discussing why i think it makes sense
for the iphone 14 pro to come with usbc
instead of lightning and within that
video i made the very important point
that when apple revealed lightning they
said that it would be the port that
they'd use for the next decade and guess
what that was 10 years ago in 2012. so
this basically confirms that either this
year or next year apple will for sure be
ditching lightning on the iphone and i
personally think it's going to be this
year because they might as well do it
alongside this new fold redesign
especially since we're expected to get a
48 megapixel camera on the pro models
for shooting 8k video so we're gonna
need the faster transfer speeds but
since making that video apple has
apparently discontinued the iphone
lightning dock which could be a major
hint that points to them beginning to
ditch lightning completely and even
though the last thing minchiko said
about usbc on the iphone was that apple
would be sticking to lightning for the
foreseeable future that was actually
back in march of last year so maybe
things have changed and that is what i'm
personally hoping for but no matter what
happens with the port the important
thing is that the dual cutout face id
display design is now confirmed to be
coming and finalized and it's gonna help
the iphone look a lot better than before
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did click that circle above
to subscribe for more videos like this
one and definitely check out some of
those videos right there including the
new samsung s22 ultra comparisons thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]